من جهته وصفا وزير الخارجيه الامريكيهن
خلال المؤتمر الصحفي الاستراتيجيه
الدفاعيه اليابانيه بانها تتفق مع تلك
التي تتبناها الولايات المتحده ورحب لينكن
بقرار اليابان زياده الانفاق الدفاعي وقال
اين واشنطن و طوكيو اتفقتا على ان معاهده
الدفاع المشترك المبرم بينهما تشمل ايضا
الهجمات التي تتم عبر الفضاء مؤكدا ان
البلدين يتفقان على ان صينيه تشكل اكبر
تحدي الاستراتيجي لهما
والدفاع الوطني وبرنامج تعزيز القدرات
الدفاعيه في اليابان لا تدعوا مجال للشك
في حرص اليابان على الاستثمار في قدراتها
للاعب ادوار جديده وتوفيق التعاون الدفاعي
اكثر فاكثر مع الولايات المتحده وشركائنا
واننا نرحب بقرار الحكومه اليابانيه
مضاعفه الانفاق الدفاعي بحلول سنه 2027 ان
استراتيجيات الياباني بعيد عن استراتيجته
الولايات المتحده